how would you today if you are the mayor
of San Francisco if you're the mayor of
Chicago You're the mayor of New York how
are you cleaning up the streets in those
cities
well I mean it's it's a little bit of a
of a of a strange question because their
political
philosophy their political temperament
there is so totally inconsistent with
running a safe City I mean every one of
their policies makes the city more
dangerous
and their allegiance is to the Democrat
Party and its left-wing philosophy not
to the people
I know Adam's the best he worked for me
for eight years as a policeman I don't
remember an arrest that he made
and he says the right things people
voted for him in New York because they
thought he was the among the Democrats
one who emphasized war and Order
he says all the right things we should
change our bail laws of course we should
we shouldn't let people out just
yesterday they let out a person they let
out a man who killed his son they let
him out on bail
no bail they just they just let them out
the guy's walking around the streets a
day after he killed his son or two days
after he killed his son that's insane
that doesn't just arguable it's just
insane uh the the it's very much a part
of uh the national Democrat approach to
Crime uh
the leader of our state legislature said
the other day you're never going to
reduce crime by incarcerating people
that's actually the only way to reduce
crime
particularly with career criminals
so uh they they would have to change
their entire first of all they have to
change their party affiliation and every
time Adam says something he doesn't go
through with it because they throw him
out of the Democrat Party if he did uh
he backs off
so this is and this is every city that
has
heavy crime it's a Democrat mayor
very often it's a Soros diet every city
you mentioned is a Soros D.A put there
to let criminals out
um for the purpose of creating chaos
in fact all of the DA's that let the
rioters go in 2020
and they're now paying them money
they're actually in New York we've paid
money to people that were arrested in
2020. they're all they all have Soros
DA's as well
and Soros is the biggest contributor
antifa the biggest contributor black
lives matter the biggest contributor to
the Democratic party the biggest
contributor to Biden and the biggest
contributor to these DA's so it's almost
in it I mean I could
be blue in the face and telling them how
to reduce crime they're not going to do
it uh they they would have to resign and
put a republican there who hopefully
would say let me look at a way it was
done before and repeat it
so you would uh hire a lot more police
we're down to 33 000 police officers
that's not enough for New York City
they don't prioritize police officers de
Blasio defunded them by a billion
dollars and Adams has never put the
money back a billion dollars taken out
of the police department
what do you think happens uh not only
that even if he wanted to hire police
officers
they're not going to be New York City
police officers all our police officers
Escape if they don't go to Florida they
go to Nassau County Suffolk County or
Suburban counties to pay the police
officers more and treat them with a lot
more respect
so he it'd be you would have to have a
mayor
that created morale in the police
department that the police department
trusted not to
jeopardize their lives in their careers
anytime there was a political
controversy uh you would have to go back
to deciding on how you enforce the law
based on comstat comstat is a program
that I invented with Bill Bratton
uh it goes back to my days in the
justice department when I handled FBI
statistics with measures crime
and locates it in exactly the places
where it's growing
and you move your police based on
statistics based on real facts not
sentiments political pressure so uh if
all of a sudden you see
three murders in a particular area
you start to move into that area try to
find out why see if you can find a
common cause you reward your police
officers not just for making arrests but
for reducing crime
and you penalize the commanders when
crime goes up so change incentives
here's what I thought I did I changed
policing
the best policing up until the time I
was mayor is based on how many arrests
you make
I reviewed an arrest as a failure
somebody's already been victimized
somebody's already been killed somebody
already been robbed somebody already
been raped interesting the real goal is
prevent it
so by using the comstat program I could
measure
when you became a commander of a
Precinct how much crime you had each one
of the categories you're talking about
and then how much you're reducing it
or how much it's going up I promoted you
if you reduced it
I put you so far away from where you
lived if it went up that you resigned uh
I'm I manage by uh
rewarding success but I define success
as reducing crime
it never happened it's very important by
the way so success to you was reducing
crime not increasing arrest absolutely I
mean increase arrest only for the
purpose of reducing crime what's the
second and so what's the second data you
track as success so first one is how you
reduce crime in your District or in your
city then what's the second one the
second one is you look at the things
that are long-term going to matter like
if you show me an increase in shooting
someplace I can tell you that six months
later you're gonna see an increase in
Murder because it's starting to move
toward violence so work on the shootings
if you start seeing a neighborhood that
had no graffiti
start to have graffiti
you know that that neighborhood is going
to become
overridden by gangs eventually they've
actually started to move in already
so get rid go after the graffiti people
because they're probably also the gang
members
uh one of the things that de Blasio did
that helped to raise crime in New York
this will sound strange is he stopped
arresting the people who were Fair
beaters on the subway
we arrested everybody who was a fair
beater never had been done before turned
out that 45 of the people will be
arrested with dangerous criminals who
will want it
so we got them we also solved a Serial
murder that way because a guy who had
never been arrested had killed two women
he was on his way to probably killing 10
or 15.
he did a he did a turnstile jump we
arrested him we fingerprinted him we
never would have fingerprinted him if he
had an arrest him and then his
fingerprint showed up on the on the uh
on the purse of the third woman that he
killed so we stopped him after three
we have a bunch of those that easily
could have been serial murders they used
to afflict New York in in the past
you've got to look for the secondary
um
characteristics that predict that you're
going to have more crime the other way
they describe that is the broken windows
Theory but they when they say the broken
windows Theory it sounds like something
silly like you know you enforce uh
people who are spitting on the sidewalk
or
no you look at what would be minor
crimes
that are in disha of a neighborhood
starting to turn
to much more dangerous crime and you do
enforcement of that and cut it out at an
early stage and it's a lot of it is
study and hard work and prediction and
statistics I never would have been able
to reduce crime
the way I did 30 years earlier without
the computer
because we never would have been able to
analyze the statistics fast enough
to turn them around and use them
to uh to act that's so weird because we
have better Predictive Analytics
technology today better data better we
should be better than everybody we
should be better at this 100 better at
it instead instead most of our
politicians particularly Democrats
engage in uh propaganda about about
about crime like how about this um
um
a cop got shot the other day Adams shows
up and says we've got to get the guns
off the street
we've got to enforce we've got to have
stronger gun control was
now Adams was a cop
what what by Nature what is a criminal a
criminal is a person whose Behavior
can't be controlled
because of his Dave it could be
controlled he wouldn't have shot
somebody
so a criminal is not going to listen or
obey the gun control was neither is a
Madman
so gun control might be good or bad it
has nothing to do with reducing crime
because criminals don't respond to
controls
they're uncontrollable that's by nature
and the more dangerous they are the more
uncontrollable they are so it's a
fantasy world to think that gun control
which may be good to reduce suicides or
accidental murders
has anything to do with crime
you want to go debate it
debate it based on its safer
you should have some of these controls
because of the accidental murders that
take place but you're not gonna you
could have all the gun control in the
world which they have in Chicago
in which they have in New York and you
can have massive number of murders Pat
if I could just add one other thing
because I researched for my last book
this very question and my answer I
basically wrote a chapter about you the
first thing that the mayor did and
correct me if I'm wrong I grew up in
Long Island so we had to come through
the Midtown Tunnel to get into the city
my grandparents lived in the city the
first thing that he did basically we had
all those guys that were standing
outside the Midtown Tunnel and they were
washing your windows with dirty water
and it set a tone for when you got into
the city so the Suburban people would
come into the city the first thing that
would happen they were basically
accosted by some version of homeless
people or whatever it might be he
immediately got rid of those people then
started cleaning up Times Square and
then suddenly all the other people that
lived in the other boroughs started
coming in and realizing oh it's kind of
clean here and then people it's what's
happening here in Florida you start
modeling something good and then people
because people are waiting for a model
all the time they don't just do it on
their own but you start getting rid of
the people that are just annoying
everybody and bother everybody and
making things dirty and uncomfortable
and next thing you know everyone else
starts to quote Jordan Peterson standing
up with their shoulders back right and
that actually is what happened and then
we had 20 incredible years I was there
for virtually I was there for all of
your mayorship Kelly carried it on and
improved it Tom your thoughts when
you're hearing this how are you
processing what he just said right now
well I
I have some firsthand experience with
San Francisco a chapter in my career you
know I lived in East Bay I took Bart
from Castro Valley to Embarcadero and
Montgomery station there's two stations
right there and I worked at 525 Market
and everything Soma South the market you
know today you hear about all these
issues and I've seen it so I've seen San
Francisco before and after and I want to
know do you think Rudy that there's also
going to be some faith in the voters the
voters in San Francisco recalled the
district attorney about a year ago now
have they got a better district attorney
we're about to find out
because it's it's coming to a head you
also have commercial space right now
occupancy and pricing and of commercial
real estate space is dropping in San
Francisco and it's not coveted and it's
not the recession it's at San Francisco
now freaking sucks and nobody wants to
put their business there and put their
people there and now we've lost a leader
from one of the pillars of San Francisco
which is the tech industry and so is
there some faith that you can put in the
voters can the voters turn the tide they
recalled the D.A the mayor is not has
been tenuously
tenuous popularity right now the mayor
which is about to go sideways because a
week ago no no not even a week it was
four days four days before the murder
the mayor punts now I think we all read
about San Francisco that they've deep
criminalized drug use you can actually
use needles you can be right there on
the street and they will not arrest them
well now the mayor has got such issues
going on with families leaving
uh
businesses leaving commercial real
estate vacancy had all these things kind
of cries uncle and asked for federal
dollars to help with the drug problem in
San Francisco joining drug problem in
San Francisco you're handing out needles
and it got worse what a shock I gave
whiskey and car keys to my son and I
wrecked the car I'm so surprised right
why are you surprised now you're crying
for federal dollars that this is true
I'm not exaggerating this saying it's
we're overrun the problems overrun and
we have so many vacancies for law
enforcement we can't fill them of course
because they don't want to why do you
want to be I'll be a California highway
patrolman in Central State why would I
say instead of doing that I'm going to
take a job in San Francisco where
there's no bullets in my gun right I'm
just supposed to show it and scare
people
you you sit there and you look at this
so I look at it and I say is there a
moment where we the people can kind of
stand up and demand change they've
recalled the D.A but is there a tide is
it because you're talking about a smart
person yourself with support from the
mayor's office and from we the people
and you're able to implement the things
you're talking about if it wasn't the
case you wouldn't have been there long
if they said oh this is too terrible
he's this is bad you're being hard on
youth all those things in the BS that
goes with that do you think there's a
tide that can turn in San Francisco for
the citizenry even though they are very
liberal on social matters look around at
the crime and what's happened to their
City
they've recalled the D.A do you think
there's a point where the people can say
enough and can start voting in favor of
being against the people that are
getting support from Sorrows
I I hate to say it I don't know it was
true 30 years ago
uh
when I got elected some other people got
elected people just were tired of the
crime and the but you look at Chicago
the other day that never should have
happened in Chicago
um
I don't know I don't know if the will is
there or or there's been such a change
in the in the attitude and I'm not
talking about America now I'm talking
about cities
I mean uh there was an article today or
yesterday basically saying San Francisco
has passed the turning point and it's
gone
uh it's a very fatalistic attitude I
hate that I mean I'm always an optimist
but so I would I would say sure there's
a chance if you elect if you elect an
independent person a a very strong
person and a person doesn't mind getting
criticized and uh evaluates themselves
you know on honest principles uh and
there are people like that and
occasionally you can vote for someone
like that but they're not the usual
person that runs for for office you get
that person particularly a mayor a mayor
a mayor in New York in particular has
great power
for good or bad uh more power in a way
in your little domain than the president
has to change things
um so yeah I mean if we if next time we
elect the right person for mayor you
could turn around New York
I think I'm not sure the San Francisco's
too far gone I hate to tell you San
Francisco doesn't need Harvey Dent it
needs Batman that that's the situation
it may be too far gone yeah I don't know
okay I think Chicago's too far gone I
think they just indicated that yeah by
the way I have the stats for the cities
when you go through the cities with the
biggest crime and you look at top 20 I
have it somewhere around here when we
were going through it it I think what
was it 27 out of 30 top cities in
America are ran by Democratic Mayors so
when you're going back and I asked a
question from you and the first thing
you said is I don't know if the question
is right because it's about politics
you're making me think about the fact
that it depends on where their policies
lie for them to execute the right thing
but here's here's one thing I would say
for the person that's watching this okay
we had a person that we're talking about
hey my kids are going to the school you
know what do I do about it I said listen
there's different levels of parenting
there's those parents that are oblivious
of what's going on in school like just
they just don't give a they don't
pay attention like ah whatever then
there's those parents that are they know
what's going on they and complain
they're not happy about it but they just
talk they don't do anything then the
third level of people is the people that
say I know what's going on I care about
it and I'm gonna run for board because
there's only a five percent uh turnout
I'm gonna go and do something about it
then the fourth step is hey I have tried
I did try to do something other parents
were not for it I've decided to you know
move to a different state okay then the
other option is I'm gonna do
homeschooling or I'm going to put them
in private school if you can afford it
right there's certain things to it if
somebody is watching this and you're
saying I wish my mayor in my city would
do this this is my suggestion to you
this part of the podcast that we just
had we're going to put a clip to it
right what mayor's suggestion was I
would share this part with as many
people in your city as possible
including with your mayor and the people
in the office and say hey here's a case
study of a guy in the last 50 years that
was able to do it better than anybody
else I don't want to leave my city I
love my city why don't we set aside the
politics whether you like this man or
not he did something in a city that
cleaned up the streets you and I were
having lunch at this restaurant over
here in in Angelo's and the owner was
there and he came up I can't even tell
you how the reaction was we're sitting
there you know and all of a sudden he's
like Tom you remember this he comes in
and he says mayor Giuliani I have to
tell you you are my hero I am Italian I
grew up in the streets I remember how
you cleaned up the streets we felt safe
for kids myself everybody you are my
hero he's saying this to him while we're
sitting having regular lunch together
and a lot of other people feel that way
as well so my suggestion whatever City
you're in San Francisco L.A Baltimore
shy time whatever it is share this part
of the message and maybe you can be the
voice the leader to help that City get
some good ideas so if you like this clip
and you want to watch another one click
right here and if you want to watch the
entire podcast click right here
thank you